this video is brought to you by audible
the disney live action remake of mulan
has some pretty terrible editing
at first i wasn't going to make this
video because i felt like it would
overlap too much with what i've already
covered in my video about bohemian
rhapsody's terrible editing but i think
the editing in mulan is bad in a
slightly different way
and i think there's an opportunity to
talk here about not just
what's bad about mulan's editing but
about why bad editing happens and whose
fault it is a much more complex and
difficult question to answer
most of mulan's editing isn't that bad
while it's not winning any awards it's
also not
mind-numbing or super distracting but
there are
several scenes that sort of boggle the
mind
the first is the opening set piece where
mulan runs through her village chasing a
[Music]
chicken
the issue with this scene is that it
often breaks continuity of action
breaking continuity isn't always bad but
it can cause
problems when it makes it unclear what
action
is happening or when the audience
notices the break in the continuity and
it creates an unwanted jarring effect
let's focus in on just a couple sections
[Music]
this cut right here is essentially a
jump cut you can obscure a significant
jump forward in time
by cutting to a different angle but this
cut isn't to
another angle it looks like it's
probably just a digital zoom
and such a small amount of zoom isn't
nearly enough to cover such a big
discontinuity in action
to make matters worse there are two of
these cuts back to back both breaking
continuity and creating a jump cut
effect
the second cut is especially offensive
because it's a cut back in time instead
of forward which makes it even more
jarring
let's look at another section
[Music]
[Music]
between these shots mulan suddenly
changes the direction she's facing and
these cuts
skip more significant portions of action
this close-up of her leg is especially
puzzling to me
it's not well composed for what it's
showing it's not really necessary to
understand the action and it's kind of
confusing in conjunction
with the other shots it seems like the
main focus of the action here would be
on her upper body and her face as she
pulls herself up onto the ledge but
that's just completely missing from the
scene altogether
a few continuity issues in a scene are
usually not a big deal
very good editing will often have small
continuity issues in the action
look at this cut from my favorite scene
in the godfather where the hand lowering
the cigarette breaks continuity
this kind of thing happens all the time
in movies and you usually don't notice
it but there are two
reasons why these continuity errors
stand out in mulan
the first is that there are so many back
to back at such a fast pace
the second is that this is an action
scene and the continuity issues are with
the primary action
continuity issues are usually more
forgivable when the focus of the scene
is on a conversation drama or an emotion
when we're focusing on people's faces we
tend to be blind to small continuity
errors in the action
but this scene in mulan is put forth as
an action scene so when you disrupt that
action
visibly it's much more noticeable
because the action is what we're
focusing on
you might notice that part of the
problem with these scenes is that
they're edited so
quickly and while that's definitely a
problem here
fast editing isn't inherently bad it
just tends to amplify
other issues in editing so i want to
mainly focus on those issues that the
fast pace of editing is merely
exacerbating
let's return to the section i showed you
at the beginning of the video
what is even going on here it just looks
like chaos
if we slow it down and look at just a
small section at a time we can see what
was
attempted and where it's going wrong
this first cut isn't that bad even this
one's
mostly fine but this one completely
interrupts the flow of action
to help hide cuts editors often time a
cut in the middle of an action
because your eyes are following the
continuing action from shot to shot the
cut becomes
less noticeable when it's placed in the
middle of that action while this cut
is technically in the middle of a single
motion it happens
right as that motion is changing
direction so when the cut happens the
action continues in a direction that is
different from the one you're expecting
which makes it confusing the biggest
defender then comes right here
the direction of action in this shot
seems to be setting up a blow to this
soldier with her staff
but in the next shot she actually seems
to be hitting him with her
arm i say seems to because you can
clearly see that she doesn't usually
filmmakers will use an angle for a
strike like this that actually hides the
lack of contact between the stunt people
but
here they choose a full profile for some
reason that completely reveals the
artifice of the moment
then we cut away to a wide if you look
closely continuity is technically
maintained here the soldier is falling
away properly behind her and her hand is
moving away in the right place
but when the clip is moving at full
speed you can't tell because the
composition blocks out the view of the
continuing action
so the effect is that there's no
continuity of movement even though there
technically is
then she reaches in to grab this guy's
neck another action which is mostly
obscured by the composition
we then cut directly across the 360
degree line of action something that's
okay sometimes but in this case just
adds to the confusion in the midst of an
already fast-paced and chaotic scene
we then immediately cut to this shot
which not only doesn't add any new
information to the scene at the cost of
the slight
disorientation of a cut but it's
actually a worse
shot the subject of the shot her face is
out of focus
i could continue to break down each cut
showing how all these little problems
add into this giant
mess but that would be tedious and long
and repetitive instead i think it's more
interesting to start trying to figure
out
why the editing is like this
the easy answer you might jump to is the
editor is a bad editor
but it's not that simple sure this could
be the case
but in filmmaking it's not safe to
assume that the editor is necessarily
the cause of these problems
if we look at some of the other scenes
in the film david coulson the editor of
the film clearly can edit a scene
there's nothing wrong with this scene
for example you must
be courageous for your mother
and your sister
for me
we also know that coulson has 44 editing
credits to his name and while experience
doesn't guarantee skill it's unlikely
he's just
a bad editor sometimes a scene will come
out like this because the editor just
doesn't have the right material to work
with or is being forced to try to cover
up
other issues with the filmmaking in a
scene like this the issues could be
bad cinematography this shot would seem
to indicate that that might be one
problem
if a wide that clearly shows the
choreographed action is never shot the
editor
just can't cut to it i think bad
cinematography is actually the main
issue
in this scene the camera is all over the
place it's on the ground it's on the
roof and almost
every cut seems to introduce a new angle
and perspective
in this village and it creates an
incredibly spatially jarring scene
something that's only amplified by the
breaks and continuity and the pace
it could also be bad stunt choreography
or performance
if the actions aren't choreographed well
it will be more difficult to properly
shoot and
edit and more mistakes or obvious
fakeness will have to be covered over
in the edit we can see some evidence
that this might be the case in moments
like this one
here she seems to grab the soldier's
throat but then a few shots later she's
obviously
not is this a flaw in performance is it
bad choreography
if issues like this are visible within
the film who knows what kind of issues
were there that we
can't see because they had to be covered
over in the editing
bad sound design can also factor in for
this shot look at the trajectory of the
throw
star the shot doesn't track with the
movement and the star clearly hits
before we hear the impact
and the stun actor flies backward well
after the impact has happened
all of this adds to the jarring
confusion of the scene
and none of it is the fault of the
editor all of these things
are things that it's the editor's job to
try to overcome
but the editor can't make something out
of nothing or
work magic on top of that toss in a
producer or director
who might be telling the editor to spice
things up and make it faster or more
exciting while working in an
environment that is pressuring you to
get things done quickly and meet
deadlines
all of this together and you can easily
see how the bad editing in a scene like
this may not be the fault
of the editor at all to complicate
things it's possible to lose sight of
a scene as you're working on it just in
making this video i've looked at these
scenes
so much that i know the action the
characters are going to take
and this knowledge makes the scene make
more sense to me and feel less jarring
than they did the first few times i
watched them
but i have to trust the experience i had
watching them the first few times
this is something called exposure
blindness and when it happens an editor
can lose sight of what it's really like
for someone to watch a scene for the
first time
this is a trap that editors have to work
to avoid and i think it's one that even
experienced editors can fall into from
time to time
it's why it's so important to bring in
fresh eyes to see your work
but whether it's the editor's fault or
not we can't really know
unless we have an objective and complete
view of the films behind the scenes
we're just left to speculate ultimately
we're faced with the fact that when we
talk about
editing and film we're really referring
to two different things
the progression from one shot to another
on the screen
and the act of editing performed by the
editor if we think about it in that way
we can say this scene has
bad editing but we can't necessarily
infer from that
that david coulson is a bad editor in
fact
given the material he had and the
problems he had to try to solve
this might have been the best he could
have done
thank you to audible for sponsoring this
video start listening with a 30-day free
audible trial with that trial you get
one
audio book that's yours to keep forever
and access to the entire plus catalog
absolutely free it's spooky season so i
want to recommend one of my favorite
horror audiobooks the area x trilogy by
jeff vandermeer is the series that the
film annihilation was based on it's not
traditional horror but it's a sort of
lovecrafty and existential
horror sci-fi that i really really
enjoyed the plus catalog has
audiobooks podcasts audible originals
guided fitness
meditation programs and sleep tracks all
of that as well as a credit for an
audiobook
every month is yours when you become a
member
at audible.com thomasflight
that's audible.com thomasflight or text
thomasflight2500 500. i'm a big fan of
audible and i want to thank them again
for sponsoring this video
start your free trial at audible.com
thomasflight or text
thomasflight to 500 500.
right now i'm letting patrons choose a
movie for me to watch every month last
month they made me watch
naked by mike thulis which i reviewed as
my bonus patron video for that month
if you're interested in joining the
discord and getting in on the
discussion go to patreon.com
thomasflight